un objeto se mueve a lo largo de una
línea la siguiente gráfica muestra la
posición del objeto en relación con su
punto de inicio a lo largo del tiempo
para cada punto de la gráfica el objeto
avanza retrocede o no se mueve pausa en
el vídeo y traten de resolverlo muy bien
tenemos la posición en metros en función
del tiempo por ejemplo este punto justo
aquí nos dice que después de un segundo
estamos cuatro metros adelante de
nuestro punto de inicio o por ejemplo
este punto de aquí dice que después de
cuatro segundos casi estamos casi a
cuatro metros atrás de nuestro punto de
inicio así que veamos cada uno de estos
puntos y pensemos si estamos avanzando
retrocediendo o no se mueve de modo que
en este punto justo aquí en ese momento
estamos a unos dos y medio metros
adelante de nuestro punto de inicio
estamos en una posición positiva de dos
y medio metros pero a medida que pasa el
tiempo nos estamos moviendo hacia atrás
cada vez más cerca del punto de inicio
así que en este punto estamos
retrocediendo una manera de pensarlo en
este momento estamos a dos y medio
metros si avanzas aproximadamente medio
segundo volveremos a nuestro punto de
inicio así que tuvimos que retroceder y
si miramos este punto justo aquí parece
que estuviéramos retrocediendo todo este
tiempo mientras nuestra curva está
inclinada hacia abajo pero en este punto
justo aquí cuando estamos casi cinco
metros por detrás de nuestro punto de
inicio comenzamos a avanzar nuevamente
pero justo en este momento no avanzamos
ni retrocedemos es justo en ese momento
en el que acabamos de ir hacia atrás y
estamos a punto de avanzar y una manera
de pensarlo es cuál sería la pendiente
de la línea tangente en este punto y la
pendiente de la línea tangente en este
punto sería horizontal por lo que en
este punto sería ninguno de los dos no
se mueve aquí podemos usar la misma
técnica con este punto la pendiente es
positiva y vemos que justo en ese
momento parece que estamos en el punto
de inicio
si avanzas incluso una fracción de
segundo ahora estamos frente a nuestro
punto de inicio así que estamos
avanzando avanza justo aquí y en este
punto estamos en nuestro punto de inicio
pero si piensas en lo que va a pasar un
momento después un momento después
estaremos un poco por detrás de nuestro
punto de inicio y aquí estamos
retrocediendo
y hemos terminado